moving from hill house to you hill house
is the first big project you comes next
what did love require from you as far as
preparation goes
that nell didn't that might have
surprised you i think a lot more
imaginative work
um in terms of um
just understanding the world in which
she was existing in
there was a lot more discomfort in
regards to clothes
everything was a lot more like
restrictive and and it's just all of the
artifice
she's very presentational and nell is
not
so it was more working on an
understanding what she's trying to
convey while simultaneously
understanding what's going on underneath
when nell's just kind of like
just like all there you know i feel like
all the hill house imagery that just
flashed through my mind right now is
wildly disturbing but wonderful
um i don't i'm not like a scary figure
in the world people look at me they run
the other direction
well i also feel like it speaks to how
effective the imagery in hill house is
like there are certain scenes and shots
in that show that i will never forget
i don't know what what you can say about
season three of you
but are you guys actively working on
that yet or do you still have to kind of
like lay low until all of this sorts out
um i think we're tiptoeing towards
working now
um i know that we have some like
meetings coming up and whatnot
but things are starting to come together
for production to start
are there any specific qualities of
loves that
you like started to tap into in season
two that you're more eager to explore
this time around
yeah the hysteria you know i mean it was
always happening
she was always kind of off her rocker
consistently
even before the kind of large uh reveal
at the end of the
season but uh
yeah i just love those when
her and joe are just going at it you
know
with all the hypocrisy it's it's
it's kind of hysterical i really want to
venture more into that